then the next thing  that i got was heat  and i remember my agent calling and said  this is a big  pacino de niro film it's it's a small  role of uh of a role called van zant  and i read it and i said i'm in he goes  it's not big and i said no but it's five  scenes and you can't cut him out of the  movie  because i learned what virtuosity i was  it was you know what what has to be in  the movie to tell the story i was inco  it was inconsequential to the story the  part that i played in virtuosity yeah  heat very consequential and i still to  this day  can read something and go  you don't need that role in the film  um  and it sometimes can make a decision  whether  you know to go with it or not